hello everyone well pleased to have you
join us for cardinal health lab exchange
welcome to today's live broadcast
assessing quality using a cure on
controls quantitative viral load asses I
am Brenda Kelly Kim lab roots now be
your moderator for today's webinar we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by sarah care sarah care
partners with IBD researchers and
manufacturers as well as clinical
laboratories to bridge the gap between
today's diagnostic solutions and
tomorrow's engineering technologies
molecular diagnostics next-generation
sequencing and companion diagnostics for
more information please visit www Sarah
care com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner of the auditorium this will
direct you to the necessary site and
form needed to receive your credits this
webcast is also designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them and
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to get to as many of your
questions as we can today you can
enlarge the slides indo by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left following the
presentation please make sure to head
over to the Sarah Kerr virtual booth
here at cardinal health lab exchange to
have the opportunity to engage in live
chat and have more of your questions
answered on the spot about assessing
quality using a key run controls the
quantitative viral load essays I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
Russell garlic
dr. garlic is a scientific and R&D
leader with over 30 years of experience
in life science industry he has led the
development of highly technical R&D
projects for new products launched into
the research translational research and
diagnostic markets he has working
experience with plasma cellular and
cell-based assays using receptor-binding
immunoassay mass spectrometry and
molecular diagnostic technologies at
Sarah Kerr life sciences dr. garlic is
currently meeting the new technology
development for IBD controls as well as
reference materials the next-gen
sequencing applications in oncology
infectious disease non-invasive prenatal
health and genetic testing when he was
at protein forest he led the development
of an isoelectric focusing chip for
protein and peptide mass spec sample
prep instrument and data analysis
software previously at any n DuPont
medical products dr. garlic led the
efforts to develop multiple diagnostic
tests used to manage eight Diagnostics
including an HIV antigen sa and an early
drug resistance sa dr. garlic has been a
member of a acc since 1992 is an
affiliate member of a ACR and is an
affiliate scientist with ACMG he has
published 13 peer review papers and has
two patents and to patent applications I
will now turn it over to dr. garlic this
presentation
well good day everybody Thank You Brenda
for that introduction welcome to the
Sarah Kerr life sciences seminar today
we're going to speak about assessing
quality using the a current controls for
quantitative viral load assays so I'm
Russell garlic I've been with Sarah care
a number of years here I'm actually
located in Milford Massachusetts we
actually have two sites one here in
Massachusetts and one in Gaithersburg
Maryland so let me go to the learner
objectives twofold one to apply biology
controls using Sigma metrics for
quantitative viral load assays to an
overall laboratory quality control
system I want to bring this to life by
using current data that would generate
in our own laboratory or reviewing some
of the virology around hiv-1 hbv and HCV
to PCR assays and using controls as part
of a laboratory QC strategy program the
agenda will be a few minutes introducing
circular life sciences spend a little
bit of time talking about the viruses
that we're talking about detecting and
of course the importance of quality
control and especially with these
quantitative biology assays in
uniqueness about quantitative
measurements in metrics will talk about
using Sigma metrics as a way to analyze
your data some specific examples from
our own laboratory and then when assays
do follow some troubleshooting ideas and
we have a list of references and of
course we can give you this entire
presentation through accessing Sarah
care and there's a number of references
that you could get access to so let's
move on to Sarah Kerr Sarah Kerr has
been in business for over 30 years
supporting advanced diagnostics company
started back in the 1980s during the
AIDS crisis using seroconversion
panels to help IBD manufacturers develop
highly sensitive and specific asses for
HIV Diagnostics the company moved into
other forms of diagnostics including
process materials other controls that
would use to validate and develop assays
and then moved as technology platforms
changed into qpcr methods Multi multi
market mixes for serology controls in
the in the year 2000 s the company's
gone through a number of iterations and
number of acquisitions most recently
we're expanding into precision medicine
although I won't speak to it today in
today's presentation we do have a
molecular center of excellence in
gaithersburg and we are focusing on
next-gen sequencing apply to oncology
and again making control standards and
reference materials for oncology
applications as well as non-invasive
prenatal screening maternal fetal
medicine so stay tuned for additional
products and technology coming from
sarah care in those application areas so
let's spend a little bit of time talking
about the viruses here's a diagram of
hiv-1 which is a retrovirus as everyone
knows the figure shows the dock shows
the very ons and of course the rnase is
a is a dark spot inside the variants now
the importance of measuring viral load
is shown here that initial upon
diagnosis you want to confirm the HIV
viral load to see how long the infection
has been going on and typically in the
US there's another retest the viral load
every six months so very really frequent
test of frequency for HIV as well as
under therapy now under therapy you can
often see the viral loads dropping to
less than 50 copies per mil now what's
really important for HIV is of course
drug resistance you know over time the
virus becomes resistance to a number of
a RT therapies and when you see copies
per millstadt to increase specifically
above a thousand copies per mil then he
have to consider resistance testing and
within the literature external quality
assessments have set the lab standard at
plus and minus point 3 log copies per
mil so that's kind of the target we want
to be setting for our assays to be able
to detect this virus now the virus is
still a major worldwide health crisis
there are 35 million people living with
HIV and AIDS around the world and still
to this day 1.5 million fatalities per
year and even in the United States
numbers of new cases continues to grow
and as you can see in the year two
thousand eleven forty four thousand
cases of new cases of infection and most
recently 2013 their numbers are actually
rivet risen up to forty seven thousand
year 2013 so that's HIV the second virus
will be talking about today is hepatitis
B virus which is double stranded DNA
virus now in this case the nap test
nucleic acid test is an indication that
virus is replicating in the person is
highly contagious and typically the
treatment regimens if the HPV DNA is
about two thousand international units
per mil on patients who are hepatitis be
antigen so this is the core antigen that
is actually expressed into the plasma of
the patients it's negative up in the
physicians and patient management you
should start treating for this infection
now a number of very large numbers here
worldwide two billion infections around
the world with 400 million carriers as
you can see by the global map the red
indicates high prevalence rates and
green lower prevalence rates but even in
the u.s. there still are a number of
acute cases per year in 3050 and year
2013 I've good news that in the u.s. at
least this is declined from 8,000 nuke
cases of two cases in year two thousand
so that's hepatitis B now moving on to
hepatitis C now on this image one thing
I wanted to point out often times you
see hepatitis C with it's a spot with
its pointy edges on its envelope
proteins and if you look at that very
young right in the middle you can
actually see the pointed edges to the
very on hepatitis C is now an RNA virus
and still can be detected with two pcr
methods and typically assays are done
for seropositive persons to convert
confirm active infection most
importantly for a drug they're pretty
choice is to determine which genotype a
person's infected with and also to
follow in monitor treatment now in the
US it's a two-thousand 10 38 active HIV
infections in 213 20013 but as we know
the chronic infection rate is very very
high in the United States particularly
the baby boomer generation as 65 per
hundred thousand and over time these
will lead to you know severe liver
disease but the good news on hcp of
course is now we have therapies that can
actually eradicate and cure the disease
so that's a little bit about the viruses
we're going to be measuring now let's
think about it from the laboratory
perspective now laboratories are under a
lot of pressure you are clear certified
and you're running probably both
laboratory developed tests in
fda-approved tests you're always under
pressure to add more new assays which is
good because we want to be able to
support patients and diagnostics as best
we can so you're under pressures to add
assays but at the same time you're under
pressure to reduce costs and you want to
be doing all of these very sophisticated
asses HIV viral load hcv hbv and all
these other assets that you're being
asked to deliver now how I like to think
about this is as shown here in the word
cloud there's really two central
components of any laboratories QC
program and
to keep patient front and center and
keep your quality control front and
center and up to date so good quality
control lead to the proper patient
results and proper patient Diagnostics
so with all of this activity go on and
as we'll talk about in today's seminar
key QC front and center and you'll be
satisfied with your patient results so
why quality controls the first reason
there's really three things you want to
be able to differentiate one is to
differentiate normal changes from
biological variation and second we'll
talk about treatment you want to be able
to follow a specific patient to make
sure they're responding to treatment and
viral load is dropping and from a QC
perspective you want to be able to early
identify any SI drift or nes a variation
over time now an example HIV no more
variation can be as high as point to 2.3
logs over time that's just normal
variation and antiviral treatment as I
mentioned earlier it's very very
effective and you can take viral loads
actually below the detection limit of
the assays also we want to be able to
detect small shifts over time and these
oftentimes happen with reagent lock
changes and clinical laboratories have
been dealing with these issues for many
many years another reason for quality
controls is you're required to perform
them in a way that helps you reduce your
costs without compromising quality and
how you do that is really emphasizing
and well thought-out lab QC and lab QC
metrics so when assays are within
quality standards it saves time and
money and reduces risk and of course
complies with any clear regulations that
we have to follow so the characteristics
of viral quality control materials now
speak to this as a manufacturer as I
said earlier you know Sarah Kerr has
been manufacturing these types of
products for over 30 years in our
strategy to to develop these products is
to use intact
virus that would represent the virus
that is being detected in the patient
sample and by knowing the genotype it
actually provides additional information
that you need for drug drug therapy we
will also want to make sure that the
control is commutable saying patient
matrix as the sample and this allows you
to monitor all aspects of sample testing
from extraction to detection to
quantitation and we also pay a lot of
attention attention to the fact that we
want you to be able to achieve the right
levels so that means that how we mean
you've actually these products we want
to make sure they go through the proper
extraction and met the performance over
the range of interest of your essays it
within clinically relevant ranges and
viral quality control materials under
the best circumstances should be
different from kit calibrators to ensure
that the QC procedures provided
independent assessment and I'll speak to
this in a bit here and typically when
you set your essays up or using an
approved kit you always have about two
levels of four positive control and one
level for a negative one negative
control and what we do it's eric here is
we make lodge stable supplies so it
allows you to test your assay this week
next week next month and in some cases
you next year gives you a nice reference
material that you can use over long
period of time as shown here in the
lower right this is rate from is L 1 5
189 requirements so control materials so
independent QC materials that's what we
produce here at sarah care the
manufacturer in this case Sara kara we
set the design of the control based on
it inputs from what the patient
Diagnostics needs in laboratory and we
view them and as the industry does is
true external independent quality
controls and our controls have both IBD
us and
marks eibd manufacturers also supplied
juicy material and let me state here
that we do not recommend replacing in
kick controls with our third party
controls you should always run the
indicate controls as recommended by the
by the manufacturer as well so the IBD
manufacturer makes in kick controls on
generally they're designed to work as a
system by the manufacturer of the
instrument of course in the assay design
and they made in-house to internal
specifications and usually have IBD see
marks as well now our brand of net
positive controls and click acid testing
positive controls of the aculon grand
and these are manufactured from intact
virus in the three examples we're
talking about today HPV is made from DNA
positive serum or plasma we dilute it to
the proper concentration for the
specifications HCV RNA positive is also
from human or serum positive plasmon
again diluted in a in a commutable
matrix to the appropriate levels HIV is
a cultured virus it's a Type B and it's
the very famous virus 85 that we
actually grow in culture but again tied
it to the proper concentrations for in
the commutable matrix and with these net
positive controls that we provide
multiple levels that that allow you to
challenge the dynamic range of your
essays and in all cases they're diluted
and patient like material making it
committable and we go through
manufacturing process where we d
carbonate dialyze and filter up plasma
that goes into making our products and
we make sure that they are nonreactive
for other infectious organisms and in
all cases they released tested on an
fda-approved qpcr SI and available to
customers around the world
now this diagram helps you as the
laboratory to decide how frequently to
run an a quality control system so
there's two options either if you're
running in LD TSA or an fda-approved
asset on the left-hand side is the lvt
or in fact if you've modified an fda
approved test the standards from is l 1
5 189 suggest running a daily control to
confirm results of meeting expected
results and run additional controls
whenever there's reagent changes or
preventive maintenance or replacement of
any critical plots or in fact if you
have a new technicians working
laboratory or any other changes that the
laboratory would see fit to run
additional controls and again the beauty
there is you can compare the results a
lot to lot with our without their party
controls so those are ldt
recommendations and on the right hand
side is the FDA approved tests and with
the FDA proof test as I said earlier you
should run the controls is recommended
by the manufacturer and the ISO
regulations suggesting running the third
party controls at each new lot or
shipment I would emphasize that in all
of these statistical measurements more
data is better so we really do encourage
laboratory directors to run and increase
the frequency even with the FDA approved
test so you have data so you can do real
statistical analysis of trends over time
so once you've decided how frequently to
run your controls then you have to think
about how to analyze them and when we
make a recommendation as to other QC
experts to use Sigma metrics and the
advantage of Sigma metrics it's a
quantitative measure for the quality of
a test it's really easy to monitor and
not only can you follow trends but it
gives you rules that you can follow and
establish before really take
you're as they live with patient samples
and it's been used in many different
areas from clinical chemistry's to
serology and it's a very straightforward
approach it's very well proven in many
types of laboratories and ultimately
make like we said earlier the goal of
any QC program is better patient kick
here and with less failures reduction
costs and reduction in risk so the Sigma
metrics roadmap it's pretty
straightforward you need to collect your
test characteristics you want to click
and calculate a sigma value and this is
taken from other industries as Sigma
value of 2 is not a very good asset and
a signal value of 6 which is super
world-class and so in most cases in a
clinical laboratory the assays for on
the range of three four and seven days
cases five but once you've established
your metrics then you select an optimal
rule helps you guide decisions with your
essays and then you can apply it in
monitor it the whole goal here is not to
keep rerunning the control over and over
again some labs have always experienced
controls that are run outside a metric
you know so the first thing you do you
don't want to go just rerun the control
you want to go to your rules and see
what the results actually mean so that's
the purpose of the other metric so I'll
spend a little bit time talking about
the statistics we won't go into this in
depth there's a lot in the literature
I'll give you some graphs to show you
how you can apply them I think that's
the best way for a webinar like this and
as you go to the references there's
there's plenty of information you can
download these these algorithms so the
Sigma statistic as shown here Sigma you
can see the equation its purpose is to
describe the overall quality of the
entire procedure so again the higher the
value higher the quality of tests only
six sigma six is super and a sigma 2 is
is not so good
the te a the total allowable error now
this is an interesting metric because it
must meet the medical decision criterion
and it makes up a combination of the
random error plus any bias that's in me
a say as i said earlier for HIV hbb and
HCV for these viral load assays
acceptable total our areas about a half
log so I have log base 10 so that's
total allowable error and then random
error has a shown as standard deviation
s or in some cases SD and band bias in a
systematic error for the true very often
times this is difficult to calculate so
what is the true value and I'll give you
some examples and how we use that here
in Sarah care then you take the data and
you plot it on a method decision job and
it's a nice easy graphical
representation of the performance of
your asset you plot on the Y the total
allowable error and on the X the
imprecision okay so this is a method
decision chat and as I said earlier it's
a graphical tool to evaluate the quality
of these tests and you should use it
during your method validation and when
you're taking on new acids to 2x to
assess the acceptability of your
performance of your essay on a sigma
scale so what we did is took some data
to give you an example we took some
capture of a data on qpcr essays and the
biasness adjournment has the deviation
from the mean from method a compared to
you know three or four other methods so
method a is kind of a benchmark and this
is often published data and then from
replica runs who are from this procedure
is real able to establish any ending
randonneur as well so here's a plot of
the method not the decision chat again
we're plotting allowable connector see a
bias on the y
access going from zero 2.5 Rick chef for
this particular application is what
we're set the spec at and the allowable
imprecision of standard deviation on the
x-axis and you can see the signal lines
two three four five six now so we have
four datasets here we have a habit real
time the blue circle rocha Cobus assay
the pinkish circle and B diamond in the
dash B and Siemens be DNA and Abby DNA
si so this is actually show some
actually all these assays of performing
very well and you can you can make some
comments that perhaps the motion coba
system is the closest to the accurate
values but all in all you know you see
very good performance here between three
and four Sigma so that's a good quick
evaluation of using these commercial
tests in this application so that's the
method decision chat that you consider
it in the beginning so then after doing
that mathematics and getting to your
your method decision church you need to
assess your quality on a regular basis
now so now we'll go back to how we use
the ecumene controls for hiv-1 hbb and
hcv and i'm going to show you some real
examples using our in-house data and
again the purpose is to monitor and show
in assays out of control and will apply
the data to leave I Jennings and control
chats which I'm sure you've all seen
it's a very nice visual on following
trends over time and then we're going to
apply the Westgard rules and rest god
rules in the oh PS shots and you can
easily access these formulas in these
equations on the west got home page in
it which is in our references so the
products that we use for this data set
or hiv-1 the Acheron 315 you can see the
regulatory clearance we actually have
four different
varies at different concentrations that
you can see on our website HCP is aculon
305 same thing we have four different
concentrations and HPV is the accurint
325 with three different series in
remember we manufacture these controls
with with real virus in a commutable
matrix to represent the patient sample
so the first thing you have to consider
is the average levels of for these
controls and statistical guidance always
suggest running is as many as you can we
like to recommend 20 replicates for any
new control so you can establish a mean
and laboratory so it's ideal to run to
dupes over 10 runs now if that's not
feasible in some of these net assays are
very expensive so it may not be feasible
from a cost perspective we're going to
give you a solution where you can access
other data produced by other customers
for that same lot of akurum control
through our equality peer review
database system and you can use this
access to this data to supplement your
own data so equality is a peer review
database sponsored by silicon the exits
through syracuse the website where your
lab can post a review lot specific
results you can compare yours this is
your lab over time and you can pair your
data versus other labs data over time as
well and and this allows you to as the
example shows here so say you couldn't
run 20 samples but you could run three
consecutive days and duplicate you to
have you'd have N equals 6 for that
specific control a lot and then you
could go to equality and you could look
for that same lot number of control and
and grab some additional data there some
additional replicants and say you
grabbed another 12 or 14 then you could
do a one-way ANOVA test to show the data
is similar and if they are similar
enough then you combine those data sets
and save yourself some money
and give you more surety for the actual
average value from those controls as we
go through the results I'll talk about
what the actual control values were for
each one of these two pcr assays solely
by jennings plot as i said earlier it
really shows the results over time and
you can set your control limits and to
three standard deviations from the
average run and it gives you a nice
quick visual to see when a procedure is
out of control or trending out of
control and what we're going to show is
actually normalize levi jennings plots
so in this case it's the observation
minus the expected value so the expected
value is the average for that plot and
we show the graphs with plus and minus
two standard deviations or three
standard deviations and so the y-axis is
actually centered around zero since
these are normalized and the next three
shots are shown with data that we've
generated in all on laboratory either
here at the milford site or at I
gatorsburg Maryland site on the motion
code blast system and we've used to 20
measurements for a training set to get
to the averages for each one of the
controls this chat is HPV and it's the
Acheron 325 run from January 2013 till
almost early September and you can see
the blue diamonds the training set and
averaged 20 on the y-axis this is all
log transformed data I should say that
you should always make sure that the
units see the logs international units
per mil or coffee spoon vellore always
unified and do lot of transformations
for this quantitative biology essays and
you can see the red line being the 2's
in the orange line beam the 3s as you
can see with the HPV there are a number
of dots or excuse me squares that they
fall outside the 2s so there is a little
bit of imprecision with this this
particular assay and we'll come back to
what that means here in a bit
we get to the eops chats so that's the
HPV hepatitis B virus here's the HIV
assay again blue diamonds are the
training set the red excuse me the green
circles the lot of a queue on 315 lot
number one 1977 to actually run in our
Gaithersburg facility we actually a move
that instrument to a Milford facility
and you can see we ran the same wat now
this is an example say you wanted to
move your instrument is a good way to
compare results from one physical
laboratory to another physical
laboratory even within the same company
so again you run the same control over
time and you can see we have just really
two outliers of how fast two standard
deviations you can see the HIV is very
consistent over the course of time
period here and again it's about it's
actually over of course in more than a
year in this case with me with the HIV
now moving to hcv again the same model
you can see the training set normalized
around zero and again a very very good
assay all the data points within two
standard deviations so that's a nice
quick way to see how the controls are
running in these assays so now how do we
apply this data to an acceptance or
rejection rule for management within
your juicy of the laboratory so in this
case we're going to recommend using
method decision I've seen using yo PS
chats and these OBS chats first and
foremost have the same setup as the
method decision style and what you do is
you plot the observed and accuracy of
the percent bias on the y-axis in the
observed and precision on the x-axis in
this case of percent of deviation of
total error then the operating lines
represent the various rule sets to fall
to identify what a process becomes out
of control if you go back to one of my
earlier comments
is that out of control from normal
biological variation or is that out of
control due to sa drift or reagent wat
change or is it a completely true assay
and it's just normal variation or the
patient is undergoing some sort of
therapeutic response and all of this
information is is readily available and
highly recommend going to the Westgard
com site to get these formulas and
graphs so for the LPS chart now that
we've got the levi Jennings data plotted
we want to see how the controls are
running and what rules we should follow
so I'm going to follow this data and
again what the oh PS chat we're showing
it's going total error is going to be
set at a hundred percent of the medical
patata boveri a shin again back to my
earlier comment of point five log for
HIV hbb and HCV on these of our
quantitative assays and we're sending
the analytical quaddle insurance at
ninety percent so ninety percent of the
processes out of control will be
identified and then we plot the essay is
persisting deviation as a percent of
total error and then have the plot share
your results you locate the nearest
operating line just above that data
point to establish the rule that you
want to follow so here's the three
datasets on a no PS chad and we're using
N equals 4 for the rule coverage and
again total operator said at a hundred
percent of the point five plus and minus
log values and with a ninety percent
error detection rate and you can see the
lines are drawn as a maximum limit
that's a very poor quality assay the 12
s roll all the way up to a 13.5 s rule
we don't the time to go through all
these rules but but since these fall
very close to the 12 s roll you can see
the HIV which is the squares on the
hcv very close pretty much just under
the 12 s line and as we saw a little bit
more variability in the hbv I say just
to the right of the to us is that we
would choose the 2's line for this
particular these particular assays as
the rule to follow now the 12 s since
it's the most efficient rule from West
God rules this would mean that the
probability of a false rejection now
rejecting a false rejection rate is just
18% so you can use that information when
you see a control falling outside of the
two standard deviation on you'll be by
jennings plots so so that's a quick
synopsis of how to use the 0 PS chats
and again I prefer you in West god.com
for information about bells now if you
do have drifted the assay and you see
values n equals 4 outside of the one of
the 2's as we just showed then you have
to do some troubleshooting and interest
here's a short list of ideas to consider
if your control is outside the expected
range you could review the trends over
time you know is there trend versus high
versus low versus the establish mean and
of course Levi genex is a nice easy way
to do that you want to confirm that the
proper reagents calibration controls
were used of course toward the right way
and handled properly we want to make
sure that your instruments are
calibrated and up-to-date and all the
preventive maintenance records are up to
date and lab tech training is up to date
never buddies use the instrument all the
procedures of all the new training
aspects to that particular protocol or
follow you know and I like to use the
word Memphis eyes follow precisely and
then of course you can follow some other
variables like lab environment to
consider to help troubleshoot if in fact
the essays is drifting
so this chat is a list of not only the
ecumene controls that we use for this
study but all the other nucleic acid
controls that are available from sarah
care today so the top three I already
spoke to and then we actually have a
multi you know like control and HIV RNA
HCV RNA hbv RNA that's the acumen 345
again the IBD siiii in health care to
mark and we've got one series of two
different kits sizes for this product
but we also have CT mg controls you have
HPV controls both HPV DNA and HPV RNA
which is most recent a new product that
will have launched we actually have a
genetics control perfected to vector
five and MTHFR that's aculon 611 also
another new product and this just over
the last six months we introduced
actually a seed if control which is a
cure on 501 that's a control set with
four unique Clostridium speed species
that you can control for so we have a
nice long list of a cure and controls in
cushing get all this information by
either visiting our trade show booth or
the website now I think one of the most
important messages from this
presentation is to remember how the
daily run controls a central to any Q
Sealab program so you can use these rent
controls these third party controls
evaluating the kits training new
technicians lab to lab comparisons lot
acceptance inter method comparisons
inter-site and of course most
importantly troubleshooting when asked
they start to drift and crawl out of
specifications and the data analysis is
documentation you know everything I
talked about with Sigma metrics you need
a common control to be able to generate
data that's associated with those
metrics
we have a number of other products to
consider in addition to run controls we
have serology controls we have a
performance panels that you can purchase
in linearity panels are very attractive
for testing of the linearity of your
essays but also the sensitivity of your
essays qualification panels we had a
number of high titer isolates Yankee
type isolates we can have Sarah
conversion panels and disease state
materials that you can search our
website for it will help you develop
interesting new passes that you might be
adding to the menu over time and of
course we've got a good list of dillians
to do it deliver your working samples so
in summary we've talked about
quantitative biology assays and how they
require full process controls we at
Sarah Kerr go to extremes to use stable
viruses manufactured at defined levels
to support your cue seen from the
metrics total error is you need to know
that and the medically allowable error
for HIV HPV and HCV is 0 point 5 the
acumen controls were developed in
manufacturable manufactured to be
committal stable over a long period is
time to allow you compare results over a
long period of time and allow you to
monitor assay processes and a critical
components to any of your juicing
management systems in the metrics and
the rules you know provide a nice
convenient easy way to use them to to
follow you processes so here's the long
list of references again you can get
them from sarah care at our booth or at
our website and let me just on behalf of
everybody here at sarah care i'm going
to say thank you for joining us at the
seminar i'll be at the booth to answer
any questions that you might have and
also like to introduce making McCutchen
who is our associate product manager
so there's Megan's email as well so when
I stop there and see if we have any
questions thank you dr. garlic for that
informative presentation we're so happy
to have you part of the cardinal health
lab exchange before we get started on
question and answer session I want to
remind our audience how they can submit
questions they can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can so the green
Q&A button is at the lower left of your
presentation window and we'll see if
anybody has anything to ask okay
probably heading all over to the booth I
want to thank again our sponsor sarah
care for making today's educational
webcast possible please make sure that
you head over to the sarah care virtual
booth following this presentation and
you'll have the opportunity to engage in
live chat with dr. garlic and your peers
and have any other questions you have
concerning assessing quality with akurum
controls or quantitative viral load
assays i also want to let our audience
know that this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing through
October of this year and you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting you to
when this broadcast is available for
replay we invite you to forward that
email to any of your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us hope to see you over the
sarah care virtual booth thank you very
much